Liz oh it was a good day for her wasn't
a guard was man she leads the pack of
the most Grammy nominations 8 yes and
keV I do this I think I know how she's
feeling among Liz owes 8 nods are the
big four record of the Year album of the
year song of the year and best new
artist on Instagram she said she's gonna
quote drink champagne and cry happy
tears I was always gonna be a career
musician I just didn't know it was gonna
be go check this out Liz oh did predict
to eat eat the Grammys would be in her
future
hey man Jesus sharing the number-2 spot
with six nods each fellow newcomers
little nas ex and Billy Eilish duh two
months ago we bet money the 17 year old
would be the youngest artist in history
to land all four top categories the
youngest ever to do that is that true
I could have bet you money that that
would never happen getting the third
most nominations is ariana grande with
five nods
earlier today we were with Grammy host
Alicia Keys who announced the nominees
with bebe Rexha Gayle King and Recording
Academy president Deborah Dugan just
feels young and fresh a little bit more
female than usual perhaps as for who was
snub Swifty's are up in arms over the
fact that lover was shut out of the
album of the Year category Taylor did
get nominated in three other categories
so
[Music]